and good afternoon thank you for joining
us today my name is chief petty officer
Robert Simpson I'm the assistant public
affairs officer for the First Coast
Guard District in Boston Massachusetts
in just a minute I'll introduce rear
Admiral John mauger commander of the
First Coast Guard District he prepared
to give you a brief
a brief update on the case going on 900
miles east of Cape Cod in the search for
five submariners
we do ask following his brief statement
we'll be able to take some a few
questions and answers we do ask that we
give everybody the opportunity to ask
one question and if we have to go
through we can be able to ask further
questions beyond that we only have time
let's say for about 10 minutes so he has
a brief statement on here and at this
time I'd like to introduce Admiral
johnmarger
good afternoon everyone I'm Maria
Admiral John auger I'm the commander of
the First Coast Guard District here in
Boston Massachusetts and in this case I
am the lead for the Coast Guard search
and rescue operations for the overdue
submersible out near the wreck of the
Titanic
yesterday afternoon we were notified by
the operator of the submersible vessel
that it was overdue and it had five
persons on board the submersible so
we're working very closely at this point
to make sure that we're doing everything
that we can do to locate the submersible
and rescue those on board our thoughts
are with the crew members and the
families of those on board this
immersible at this time and we are doing
everything that we can do to make sure
that we can locate and rescue those on
board
so after receiving the call we launched
uh well reached out to the vessel polar
prints and began a surface search
looking for the submersible at the same
time we launched a C-130 aircraft to
search to conduct an aerial search both
Visual and radar of the scene we've
subsequently coordinated with the
Canadian Coast Guard and Canadian Armed
Forces to deploy additional assets to
this scene the Canadians have had a
C-130 aircraft searching as well in
addition to also having a p8
submarine search aircraft deploy as well
and put sonar buoys in the water in
attempt to listen
this uh the location of the search is
approximately 900 miles east of Cape Cod
in a water depth of roughly 13
000 feet it is a remote area and it is a
challenge to conduct a search in that
remote area but we are deploying all
available assets to make sure that we
can locate the craft and
rescue the people on board going into
this evening we will continue to fly
aircraft and move additional vessels
into the area in this remote part of our
search and rescue responsibility
oftentimes we rely on Commercial
operators to be the first vessels on
scene and so we've been in touch with
additional commercial vessels that are
operating in the area as well as
initiating the movement of additional
Canadian Coast Guard assets and U.S
Coast Guard surface asset into the area
over the course of the next couple of
days
adding to the complexity of this case is
the fact that this was a submersible
vessel and so we need to make sure that
we're looking both on the surface for
the vessel if it had surfaced back to
the water but had somehow lost
Communications with the vessel and
that's what the aircraft and the surface
search vessel is allowing us to do right
now but we're also having to search in
the water column and we're doing that
right now with the use of sonar buoys
and sonar on the ship that's out there
to listen for any sounds that we can
detect in the water column over the
course of the next couple days we
anticipate adding additional capability
to conduct additional search in the
water as those commercial assets arrive
on scene
again our thoughts are with the families
and the crew members on board the
submersible and we're working very
closely with all U.S and international
Partners uh to
um
provide any capability that we can
provide to search for the the overdue
vessel and rescue the crew members on
board at this point we'll take questions
[Music]
so in terms of locating the overdue
submersible we have to make sure that
we're looking on both the surface using
aerial and and surface vessels but then
expanding into underwater search as well
right now our capability is limited to
uh sonar blues and listening for sounds
but you know we're working very hard to
increase the capability we understand
from the operator of the vessel that the
vessel was designed with a 96 hour
sustainment capability if there was an
emergency on board and so we're using
that time making the best use of every
moment of that time to locate the vessel
support exactly exactly and for
something an Amish gardening a British
Explorer he confirmed that he's on board
at this point I'm not in a position to
confirm the identity of anybody on board
the vassal out of respect for the
families were you know going through the
notification process and more updates
will be forthcoming certain people
here but um it seems like if that
vessels will be sitting on the bottoms
inside
the race to get some sort of rescue
vehicle down to it
correct about that that that's
absolutely part of the overall planning
for this search case right now we're
focused on locating the vessel but at
the same time if we find this vessel in
the water then we will have to affect
some sort of rescue or coordinating
reaching out to different partners
within the U.S Navy within the Canadian
Armed Forces and within Private Industry
to understand what underwater rescue
capability might be available
on the way down
we could get down there so at this
moment we're focused on the search and
understanding the capabilities of the
vessels uh that are deploying to the
scene
so the sonar capabilities within the
sonar buoys and within the whole of the
commercial vessel that is out there
operating on site those aren't Coast
Guard sonars they are capable of
listening to a depth of 13 000 views I
understand
here you mentioned
there were 96 hours of oxygen but how
much of the 96 hours
so uh in terms of the square mileage of
the search I don't have that number
right at this moment but it includes
both a surface area that we're looking
at and a subsurface area and so we'll
get you the the exact number for the
square mileage of the search in terms of
the hours uh we understood that that was
96 hours of rescue or emergency
capability from from the operator and so
we anticipate that there's somewhere
between uh 70 to the full 96 hours
available at this point
[Music]
Titanic
and challenges with sonar and a debris
field that's the Titanic
so it's certainly the purpose of the
submarine was to as I understand the
purpose of this submersible was to
provide opportunity to visit the Rec
site and explore the wreck site so
that's that's a possibility again right
now our focus is getting on as much
capability into the area as we can and
understanding that full capability of
those assets that are being deployed our
aerial assets that are being deployed
have the capability to do both Visual
and radar searches and and the Canadians
Assad had the ability to drop sonar
buoys and listen and so we're using all
that information to improve our search
capability
foreign
we're working through that right now
um but what we're really focused on uh
at the moment is really locating the
vassal which could either be in the
surface or subsurface and so we're
bringing in technical expertise to
understand uh both the Dynamics of
underwater search and underwater rescue
operations
so uh as search and rescue professionals
uh you know we work very very hard and
and our crews take this personally our
first thoughts are with the uh the crew
members and the families of those on
board and so we want to make sure that
we have done absolutely everything that
we can do to locate uh their family
members and bring them home safe and so
they're first and foremost in our
thoughts uh every moment of uh this uh
search operation
attract students
are they even without
emergency
I I don't have any details on how often
folks visit the Rec site there at
Titanic nor the any specific comments on
the dangers involved certainly every
time ships go to Sea they encounter
hazards and dangers and so having
properly prepared vessels properly
prepared crew members and making sure
that you practice emergency procedures
good good practical advice for anybody
that goes to see
speaking
so at this point I'm not going to just
discuss any information about the
families and Communications with the
families and so we'll we'll provide that
with future updates
dozens hundreds so the Coast Guard has
two C-130 aircraft in addition to the
command team that's working here we have
two C-130 aircraft deployed the
Canadians have a C-130 aircraft and a p8
aircraft we also have access to and and
will launch this evening a C-130
aircraft from the New York National
Guard to make sure that we have air
assets sufficient air assets up there on
the surface we have the commercial
operator that's been on site and we're
bringing additional surface search
assets into play which will also bring
in some subsurface search capability
last question please
I understand from the operator that
there was one pilot or submersible
Commander operator on board and that
there were four mission Specialists on
board is the term that the operator uses
for so five five total you have to ask
the operator what that means what we're
focused on is finding those five people
thank you very much for your time
thank you for coming today let's just
conclude this portion of the briefing
um I can stay behind just to take any
other questions down and we can get back
to you at a later time and uh we'll
we'll be able to connect with you I know
you had the question about the square
mileage area
do you have a do you have a card with
you okay
with any other additional questions
so I'm not certain the exact time but
when it started as far as the the
communications on there was the 96 hours
total on on there I'm not sure if that's
the amount of time total that it can
stay underwater or if that starts
another time we can clarify and get back
to you on that
right when did that clock start for the
96 hours
yeah no I we don't have any information
on the specifics of
how the submersible setup or for any
kind of birds as far as we know we don't
have any of that we don't know that yet
we do know that the aircraft that we
have on scene that are that are
searching area can search a large area
within that period of time over assets
um so if they're if they're on the
surface we'd be able to see them at the
cruise
you mean for the persons on the
submarine itself I don't know I don't
know what the experience levels
no we don't have any indication anything
like that there's only just that the
communication had had been lost
um not specifically like necessarily
what was said on there but it was about
an hour and 45 minutes into their dive
was the last communication the last
recorded communication that they had I
don't
have specifics on if it was stopped
suddenly or if it was just
a check-in period of time they just
didn't but
I believe that was sent I think the dive
started on Sunday
I believe C's right now are three to six
feet with low visibility with fog
is what
three to six foot Seas yeah
for that far offshore is a fairly
normal I mean it's it's it does get much
higher than that during storms
[Music]
more than likely it will I think just to
keep this as kind of a central location
if we moved it down to the base would be
much more difficult for you guys to get
on
so if we do more briefings we'd likely
probably put it here and next time we'll
have more advanced notice from when we
did this we just want to make sure we
got something out as soon as we could
today we could try and meet that but
we'll send out more updates on the site
plus also Twitter to keep not only like
upching like updating information but
also the next briefing which likely
won't be until tomorrow
okay
thank you